who is throng the new Big Bad of the
Star Wars universe is all the
live-action storylines are headed to
their own crossover film directed by
Dave filoni thrawn is becoming more and
more important it was announced that
he's going to be played in live action
by Lars Mickelson who voiced the
character in Star Wars Rebels and his
brother to Galen urso actor mads
Mickelson thrawn was first introduced in
1991 in Timothy zahn's novel heir to the
Empire the first of the Legends thrawn
Trilogy in these books thrawn was
introduced as a genius Naval Commander
for the Empire with Captain Pelion at
his side and peleon actually showed up
in the Mandalorian chapter 23 played by
Xander Berkeley in 2015 Disney bought
lucasfilm and they re-categorized all
expanded universe fiction as Legends but
in the years since Dave filoni has
gradually begun to recanonize certain
elements from Legends and titles like
Star Wars Rebels the Mandalorian and the
Book of Boba Fett naturally thrawn was
one of the first of these brought in as
the main antagonist in seasons 3 and 4
of rebels